THE GRAND DOLBY THEATRE
HAS BEEN HOME
TO THE ACADEMY AWARDS
SINCE 2002.
AND WE'LL BE BACK HERE
AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
BUT THE TIMES HAVE CALLED FOR A
PAUSE WHILE WE GRAPPLE WITH ALL
THE CHANGES AROUND US.
THE TIMES ARE ALWAYS CHANGING OF
COURSE, BUT IT'S FASCINATING HOW
OFTEN THEY REPEAT THEMSELVES.
LET ME SET THIS SCENE.
IT'S A RAGING TAIL
END OF A PANDEMIC.
MANY MILLIONS OF LIVES ARE LOST.
MANY MILLIONS MORE PERMANENTLY
DISLOCATED AND CHANGED FOREVER.
PEOPLE WONDER,
HOW WILL WE MOVE FORWARD?
THE YEAR IS 1921.
AFTER THE WORST PANDEMIC IN
HISTORY, ACTORS MARY PICKFORD
AND JEAN HERSHOLT TOOK ACTION
RAISING MONEY FOR THE MOTION
PICTURE AND TELEVISION FUND
A FOUNDATION THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A REMARKABLE RANGE
OF HEALTH SERVICES AND
AID TO ANYONE WHO
WORKED IN THE FILM OR
TELEVISION INDUSTRY.
100 YEARS LATER, WE FIND OURSELVES
IN ANOTHER GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THIS TIME, THE MPTF KNEW HOW TO
ANSWER THE CALL
BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN
DOING IT FOR DECADES.
IN 1942, THE MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION FUND BROKE GROUND ON
WHAT WOULD BECOME THE
LEW WASSERMAN CAMPUS
IN WOODLAND HILLS.
FROM ACTORS TO MAKE-UP ARTISTS.
FROM ELECTRICIANS TO CARPENTERS.
FROM PAINTERS TO TEAMSTERS,
THE MOTION PICTURE AND TELEVISION
FUND WAS CREATED TO HELP THOSE
WHO, FOR WHATEVER REASON,
FELL ON HARD TIMES.
THE FILM LAB CHEMIST WHO
DEVELOPED ALZHEIMER'S FOUND A
HOME AT THE MPTF.
A GAY HAIR AND MAKE-UP ARTIST
WHOSE DEATH LEFT HIS LIFE
PARTNER UNABLE TO RECEIVE HIS
PENSION BECAUSE THEIR 40-YEAR
UNION WAS NOT RECOGNIZED
AS A MARRIAGE.
THE MPTF WAS THERE TO HELP.
>> BEING A SINGLE MOTHER IN THIS
INDUSTRY IS HARD.
BUT HAVING MY SON LOSE HIS
FATHER MADE IT A LOT HARDER.
BUT NAOMI AND MPTF
WERE THERE FOR US.
>> MY FAMILY AND I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER THE GRACE WITH WHICH
MY HUSBAND TRAVIS DIED, AND THE
MOTION PICTURE TELEVISION FUND
THAT ALLOWED HIM TO DEFINE
THE TERMS OF HOW THAT HAPPENED.
>> I HAVE A SPECIAL
CONNECTION TO THE MPTF.
WHEN MY MOTHER, PEGGY, A FORMER
ACTRESS, WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S, THE MPTF OFFERED
HER A CARING AND LOVING HOME FOR
HER FINAL YEARS, AS WELL AS HER
LAST SWEET ROMANCE.
TODAY, OVER 250 RESIDENTS CALL
THE WASSERMAN CAMPUS THEIR HOME,
THEIR AGES RANGING FROM OVER
60 TO NEARLY 100.
THESE GLORIOUS PEOPLE HOLD THE
HISTORY OF FILM AND TELEVISION
IN THEIR STORIES AND
EXPERIENCES.
KEEPING THESE RESIDENTS SAFE
DURING COVID, SEEING TO THEIR
HEALTH NEEDS, KEEPING THEM
SOCIALLY DISTANCED AND SOCIALLY
CONNECTED WAS AN
OVERWHELMING CHALLENGE.
BUT THE MPTF STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS
NEVER LEFT THEIR SIDE.
OFTEN SACRIFICING TIME
WITH THEIR OWN FAMILIES
TO TAKE CARE OF THE RESIDENTS.
QUITE SIMPLY, THEY
ARE OUR HEROES,
WORKING BEYOND
THE CALL OF DUTY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT'S THE 100TH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE MPTF AND WE HAVE WITH US
70 OF THOSE VACCINATED HEALTH
CARE AND SOCIAL WORKERS WHOSE
COMPASSION COMPELLED THEM TO
STEP UP AND TAKE ACTION TO HELP
THOSE IN NEED.
IT IS WITH INFINITE GRATITUDE
AND GREAT PRIDE, THAT WE
HONOR THEM ALL TONIGHT.
ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION FUND, CEO BOB BEITCHER
IS HERE TO ACCEPT THIS YEAR'S
JEAN HERSHOLT HUMANITARIAN AWARD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
BRYAN, THANK YOU FOR
THOSE KIND WORDS.
THEY MEAN SO MUCH TO US, COMING
FROM A MEMBER OF OUR MPTF FAMILY.
JENNIFER, NORMA, AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO
DAVID RUBIN, DAWN HUDSON, AND
THE ACADEMY BOARD OF GOVERNORS
FOR RECOGNIZING THE MOTION PICTURE
AND TELEVISION FUND TONIGHT
WITH THIS VERY SPECIAL HONOR.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THE AWARD HAS GONE
TO AN ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU TO OUR BOARDS,
WHO HAVE GUIDED US
AND SUPPORTED US OVER THE YEARS.
YOUR KIND WORDS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WERE CHERISHED.
MUCH APPRECIATION TO THE THOUSANDS
OF SMALL AND LARGE DONORS WHO
SUSTAIN OUR CHARITY AND TO OUR
VOLUNTEERS WHOSE CONTRIBUTION
OF THEIR PERSONAL TIME
IS SO ESSENTIAL TO OUR MISSION.
HERE'S TO THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF FREELANCE WORKERS IN OUR
ENTERTAINMENT COMMUNITY.
THOSE IN FRONT OF
AND BEHIND THE CAMERA.
THEY ARE THE HEARTBEAT OF OUR
INDUSTRY AND FOR 100 YEARS
MPTF HAS BEEN THEIR
SAFETY NET OF SUPPORT.
THIS YEAR ALONE, MPTF
CONNECTED WITH OUR
INDUSTRY WORKFORCE
OVER 40,000 TIMES.
THANK YOU TO THE RESIDENTS OF
THE ICONIC MOTION PICTURE HOME.
THEY'VE HAD A VERY ROUGH
12 MONTHS OF SOCIAL ISOLATION.
TONIGHT THOUGH, THEY'RE ALL TOGETHER,
BUT SOCIALLY DISTANCED AND
WATCHING THE OSCARS.
TO NORMA CARRANZA, NURSE,
AND TO JENNIFER JORGE, SOCIAL WORKER,
BOTH OF WHOM EXEMPLIFY
THE BEST IN THEIR FIELDS,
AND TO THE REST OF OUR
MPTF WORK FAMILY
ON THE FRONT LINE
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THE SOCIAL WORKERS AND NURSES,
DOCTORS AND HOUSEKEEPERS,
ACTIVITY STAFF AND FOOD SERVERS,
ACCOUNTANTS, FUNDRAISERS,
I.T. TECHS, PRODUCERS,
H.R. PROFESSIONALS,
CHAPLAINS, COOKS,
AND LANDSCAPERS,
THEY ARE OUR INDUSTRY'S
SUPERHEROES OF 2020.
THIS AWARD IS FOR THEM AND THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WHO
HAVE WORKED AT MPTF
OVER THE PAST 100 YEARS.
IT'S THE HONOR OF A
LIFETIME FOR ALL OF US
TO WORK TOGETHER AND TO
RECEIVE THIS AWARD.
WE REALLY AND TRULY
TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN.
AND TO JEAN HERSHOLT, HUMANITARIAN AND
OUR PRESIDENT AT MPTF FOR 18 YEARS,
WE'RE BRINGING YOU HOME TONIGHT.